[Music]
in tonight's democracy 20/20 report the
vastly different strategies for the two
major parties as they prepare for their
summer conventions Republicans want to
throw a party Democrats are going to
keep it mostly digital and correspondent
Peter Doocy tells us tonight from
Maryland that that Democrat tactics
tactic could extend throughout much of
the campaign if Joe Biden is elected
president he's hinting at an executive
order that would read something like
this by the authority vested in me as
president by the Constitution in the
laws of the United States of America it
is hereby ordered as follows everyone
must wear a face mask you would in
effect mandate the wearing of matters
that do everything I'm not possible to
make it make it required the people had
to wear masks in public as Republicans
plow ahead with plans for a large
in-person convention in Jacksonville
this summer in a state where the
Republican governor is delaying the next
phase of reopening amid a spike in
Kovach cases Biden says it's probable
when he's at the Milwaukee Convention to
accept the Democratic nomination it'll
be in an empty room and he doesn't think
any large campaign rallies are in the
cards between now and Election Day if
the virus were under control and moved
and we had like he talked about a
vaccine that we had ways in which to
make sure that this was not being
transmitted then yes but I don't see
that happening
Biden's event Thursday was only for a
small group of invited guests and a
small press pool to maximize social
distancing but a local outlet from the
host city Lankester online was shut out
and their editorial board is not happy
quote by shutting LNP Lankester online
out of an important community health
discussion held here Thursday the Biden
campaign sent the wrong message about
the importance of local newspaper
journalism to the very communities it is
trying to reach during the presidential
campaign thank you guys the small press
poll that was inside was instructed to
move locations mid event so the network
feed cuts out at what sounded like quite
an overestimation now we have over 120
million dead from Kovan hundred I mean
that's where the video ends but this
afternoon an audio recording has
surfaced where Biden does immediately
correct himself to say there have been
120 thousand
not 120 million which would be more than
a third of the US population Brett all
right Peter thank you